This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 2012, Michael Phelps was at the peak of his career. At the London Games, he became the most decorated Olympian of all time. He's coming hard, Phelps, he's still a chance, he's a real big chance, can he do it again, he hits it, and he does. Remarkable, stunning. He had 22 Olympic medals to his name, including 18 gold medals. The swimmer's entire life had centered around his.
这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2012年，迈克尔·菲尔普斯迎来了职业生涯的巅峰。在伦敦奥运会上，他成为了历史上获得奥运奖牌最多的运动员。他正奋力冲刺，菲尔普斯，他还有机会，这是一个绝佳的机会，他能再次做到吗，他触壁了，他做到了。卓越，惊艳。他名下拥有22枚奥运奖牌，其中包括18枚金牌。这位游泳运动员的整个生活都围绕着他的
sport at being the best. Early mornings, endless training. He pursued victory tirelessly, and it paid off. And his team maintained this extraordinary record. But then, it was over. No more early morning practices, no more races, no more gold medals to chase. He described the feeling as a post-Olympic depression. I saw myself as strictly a swimmer, not as a human being, he said. At times, he felt like he did not want to be alive. Eventually, the great athlete turned to advocacy, using his experience to raise awareness about mental health. He realized that retirement was scary because he had to find,
体育事业和力求卓越展开。清晨的训练，无休止的练习。他孜孜不倦地追求胜利，而这也得到了回报。他的团队也保持着这项非凡的纪录。然而随后，这一切都结束了。不再有清晨的训练，不再有比赛，不再有需要追逐的金牌。他将这种感觉描述为奥运会后的抑郁。他说，我把自己仅仅看作一名游泳运动员，而不是一个有血有肉的人。有时，他觉得自己甚至不想活下去了。最终，这位伟大的运动员转向了公益倡导，用自己的经历来提高人们对心理健康的认识。他意识到退休之所以让人感到恐惧，是因为他必须去寻找，
quote, whatever it was, I was looking for. Michael Phelps' experience illustrates a challenge many of us face. When the rules we've relied on to live a good life stop working, where do we find new rules? How do we discover what we are looking for? Over the next couple of weeks on Hidden Brain, and in a companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, we look at the misguided beliefs that get in the way of living a rich and meaningful life and an unlikely source that may have the answers we need.
用他的话来说，无论那是什么，正是我一直在寻找的东西。迈克尔·菲尔普斯的经历说明了我们许多人所面临的一个挑战。当赖以过上美好生活的规则不再起作用时，我们在哪里能找到新的规则？我们如何发现自己真正在寻找什么？在接下来的几周里，在“隐藏的大脑”节目中，以及在“隐藏的大脑Plus”的特别节目中，我们将探讨那些阻碍我们过上丰富而有意义的生活的错误信念，以及一个可能拥有我们所需答案的意想不到的源泉。
What is the meaning of life? Many of us have asked a question like this at some point. It's a big question, perhaps too big. But as creatures who are wired to make meaning of the world around us, we cannot help ourselves. At Stanford University, Dave Evans studies how questions like this often lead us astray. Dave Evans, welcome to Hidden Brain. Shager, good to be with you. Dave, you graduated from college in the 1970s with a degree in thermoscience.
生命的意义是什么？我们许多人在某个时刻都问过类似的问题。这是一个宏大的问题，或许过于宏大。但作为生来就要为周围世界赋予意义的生物，我们对此情不自禁。在斯坦福大学，戴夫·埃文斯研究了为什么这类问题常常把我们引入歧途。戴夫·埃文斯，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。尚卡尔，很高兴能和你在一起。戴夫，你是在20世纪70年代大学毕业的，获得了热科学学位。
What is thermoscience and what were your hopes and dreams at the time? Well, it's in the mechanical engineering department. I got my bachelor's of science in mechanical engineering, and there are two divisions of that department, the thermoscience division. mechanical engineers burn things, the kind of the power and engine guys, and some mechanical engineers make mechanisms that kind of, you know, bend and forge things, mostly out of metal. So I ended up on the thermo side of the house, the guys that make engines, because I cared about the energy problem, and my master's degree was in thermosciences. So I graduated actually with a degree paid for by Chevron Research, the oil company, paid for my master's degree, and I became a certified, advanced
什么是热科学，你当时有什么样的期望和梦想？嗯，这是机械工程系里的专业。我获得了机械工程学士学位，那个系有两个分部，一个是热科学分部。机械工程系里烧东西的人，也就是动力和发动机方面的专家，还有一些机械工程系的人制造各种机构，你知道的，主要是用金属来弯曲和锻造零部件。所以我最终进入了热科学这一块，也就是制造发动机的那群人，因为我关心能源问题，我的硕士学位也是热科学。所以我毕业时，我的硕士学位实际上是由石油公司雪佛龙研究公司资助的，我在1976年成为了一名认证的高级
energy technologist in 1976. What did you want to do with this? How did you want to make a difference to the world? It was very simple. I wanted to solve the energy crisis. I had an absolute epiphany. I was waiting in line at a store one day, and there was a television playing up in the corner
能源技术专家。你想用这个做什么？你希望如何为世界带来改变？这非常简单。我想解决能源危机。我当时顿悟了。有一天我在商店里排队，商店角落的一台
of the store, and the news was on, and gasoline had suddenly hit a dollar a gallon. A dollar a gallon, 1973. And I said, that's got to stop. We've got to get off this oil thing. that's what I need to do. I have to solve the energy crisis. So that's all I was trying to do.
电视正在播放新闻，汽油价格突然飙升到了一美元一加仑。一美元一加仑，那是1973年。我说，这必须停止。我们必须摆脱对石油的依赖。这就是我需要做的。我必须解决能源危机。所以这就是我当时试图做的一切。
So you graduated in 1976. What was the world like at that time and was the world ready for your, for your miraculous discoveries? Well, the world was doing all kinds of things, you know, we're still reeling from trying to end the Vietnam War. Civil rights was going full blast. I'm a full-on boomer, so we were trying to change the world. I gave myself a trip all the way around the country in a beat-up old van. as my graduation president, and it was a great summer because that was the bicentennial. So I went to about 15 different apple pie contests across the country. So there was a lot of Americana, there was a lot of stress.
所以你在1976年毕业。当时的世界是怎样的，世界准备好迎接你那些奇迹般的发现了吗？嗯，世界在发生着各种各样的事情，你知道的，我们仍然在努力摆脱越战结束带来的动荡。民权运动正在如火如荼地进行。我是地道的婴儿潮一代，所以我们当时正试图改变世界。我奖励了自己一次环游全国的旅行，开着一辆破旧的老旧面包车。作为我的毕业礼物，那是个很棒的夏天，因为那是美国建国二百周年。所以我去了全国大约15个不同的苹果派比赛现场。所以当时有很多美国本土文化，也有很多压力。
It was a really confusing time, but it was certainly we have to fix the world. And I was quite convinced I was ready to do that because we had the technology, we had the right ideas, but what we were missing was the social will. There was a small fact that was left out of the brochure of my master's degree, which is, it's very difficult to get a job in an industry that doesn't exist yet. So I was all dressed up for a party that hadn't started. I spent four years profoundly unsuccessfully
那是一个非常混乱的时期，但大家坚定地认为我们必须修复这个世界。我深信自己已经准备好去做了，因为我们拥有技术，拥有正确的理念，但我们所欠缺的是社会意愿。我的硕士学位宣传册上漏掉了一个小事实，那就是：在一个尚不存在的行业里找工作是非常困难的。所以我盛装出席了一场尚未开始的派对。我度过了极其失败的四年，
looking for a job that didn't exist and why I was really upset. I understand that you eventually pivoted and found a job at a small tech company. Yes, there's a little outfit called Apple, actually. It's a very long story as to how that occurred. It began actually with a phone call, I had a welding torch in my hand.
一直在寻找一个根本不存在的工作，当时我真的非常沮丧。我听说你最终进行了转型，在一家小型科技公司找到了一份工作？是的，其实是一家叫苹果的小公司。这背后的故事非常漫长。这一切其实始于一个电话，当时我手里正拿着焊枪。
I had a little solar energy startup that, of course, miserably failed because it was way too soon. And the guy said, my name is so-and-I'm from Apple Computer. We'd like to talk to you. And I said, no, you want to talk to the Dave Evans at Hewlett-Packard. That's the one who likes computers. I don't, and I hung up. And there are lots of Dave Evans. You can get them in 24-packs at Costco.
我当时有一个小型太阳能初创公司，当然，它惨遭失败，因为这个想法出现得太早了。那个人说，我叫某某，来自苹果计算机公司。我们想跟你谈谈。我说，不，你想找的是惠普公司的那个戴夫·埃文斯。那是喜欢计算机的那个。我不喜欢，然后我挂了电话。而且叫戴夫·埃文斯的人很多。在好市多你可以买到24包装的。
And I was sure that the other Dave Evans, who I knew worked at Hewlett-Packard and liked computers was the guy they wanted. And a very long story later, including 14 interviews and sitting down for lunch with Steve Jobs, they surprised themselves by offering me a job into my great shock. I took it. And that's how my high-tech career started. But it was the last thing I wanted to do. Now, you've been on Hidden Brain previously, Dave.
我确信另一个我知道在惠普工作并且喜欢计算机的戴夫·埃文斯才是他们想要找的人。经过了一个很长的故事之后，包括经历了14轮面试以及与史蒂夫·乔布斯坐在一起吃午饭，他们出人意料地向我提供了一份工作，这让我大为震惊。我接受了。我的高科技职业生涯就是这样开始的。但这其实是我最不想做的事。现在，你以前也来过“隐藏的大脑”，戴夫。
And you told us the last time that while at Apple, you helped to design the world's first mouse? That's correct. I was in charge of peripheral product marketing. The two fun things I did was I did the mouse. the first mouse for Apple. I organized. I didn't design it myself, but I organized the team of people who did. And I got to work on laser printing and do this thing called desktop publishing before anybody knew what that was. Now, many people would say that you hit the jackpot. You started working for Apple before it became the Apple that we know today. And the work you were doing
你上次告诉我们，在苹果工作期间，你参与设计了世界上第一个鼠标？没错。我当时负责外设产品的营销。我做的两件好玩的事，一件是做了鼠标。苹果的第一个鼠标。我组织了团队。虽然不是我自己设计的，但我组织了负责设计的团队。我还参与了激光打印工作，并在任何人知道那是什么之前，做了被称为桌面出版的东西。现在，许多人会说你中了头奖。你在苹果成为我们今天所知的那个苹果之前就加入了。而且你当时在做的工作
was having an impact. Did you wake up every morning feeling like you were doing something meaningful? Well, yes and no. I mean, the work we were doing, which was at the beginning of a shift of how technology serves people was a big deal. But let's be clear, what I was doing was making stuff. We were making, you know, plastic things with wires in them. And so then I just thought, you know, and if I don't do it, somebody else will. And I mean, so of the incredibly important things I worked on are long gone. Not only are they replaced by later generation in things, they're completely gone.
正在产生影响。你每天早晨醒来时，都会觉得自己在做有意义的事情吗？嗯，可以说是，也可以说不是。我的意思是，我们当时在做的工作，正处于科技如何服务人类这一变革的开端，这确实是一件大事。但我们要坦白，我当时在做的是制造东西。我们制造的，你知道的，是里面带有电线的塑料制品。所以当时我就想，你知道的，如果我不做，别人也会做。我的意思是，我曾经参与过的那些极其重要的项目早已消失不见了。它们不仅被后来的技术所取代，而且是彻底消失了。
Nobody even does that stuff anymore. It's like, what is that? It doesn't even matter. And by the way, it's not going to last. So is that all there is? I want to talk about a couple of other examples of people who felt like their lives had become dead ends, even though from the outside it might feel like they had not. Years later, after you left Apple, you began teaching at Stanford.
甚至没有人再做那些东西了。这就好比，那是什么东西？它甚至根本不重要。而且顺便说一句，它也不会长久。难道生活仅此而已吗？我想谈谈其他几个例子，这些人觉得他们的生活已经走入了死胡同，尽管从外表来看，他们可能并不觉得如此。在你离开苹果多年后，你开始在斯坦福大学教书。
You were giving a talk to a room full of accountants in Kansas City. When a woman whom you called Allison came up to you with a question, what was the question she asked you? Well, she really started with, what's wrong with my life and what did I do wrong? And she described this success that didn't work out as she had hooked. So she was an accountant, which is what everybody in the room was. She ran a small business, successfully doing accounting and taxes for about 50 other small businesses. She was happily married. She had two children.
你在堪萨斯城给一屋子会计师做演讲。当时，一位被你称为艾莉森的女士带着一个问题向你走来，她问你的问题是什么？嗯，她其实是以这句话开始的：我的生活怎么了，我到底做错了什么？她描述了那种并没有如她所愿带来预期效果的成功。所以她是一名会计，这也是房间里所有人的职业。她经营着一家小企业，成功地为大约50家其他小企业提供会计和税务服务。她婚姻美满。她有两个孩子。
She had a three-bedroom house. She had a car mostly paid for. So she had exactly everything that she had ever tried to get in her life. She was living exactly the life she had in mind. And it wasn't that she was even bored. It's just something was terribly missing. And what have I done wrong? I mean, she really thought she did it all right.
她有一栋三居室的房子。她有一辆基本上已经付清贷款的车。所以她拥有了她在生活中曾经试图得到的一切。她过着完全符合她设想的生活。而且她甚至不觉得无聊。只是有什么东西缺失了，而且缺失得厉害。我究竟做错了什么？我的意思是，她真的觉得自己把一切都做对了。
But her experience of it was not what I had in mind. And I have no idea why. She was really stuck. In some ways, this is not that different than your thermoscience story. You know, you came up with a model for what you wanted to do. You were doing a lot of stuff. But in some ways, you suddenly encountered some. aspect of the world that was not what you had prepared yourself for and you found yourself stuck?
但她对生活的实际体验并不是她脑海中所想的那样。而且我完全不知道为什么。她真的卡住了。从某种程度上说，这其实和你的热科学故事并没有太大区别。你知道的，你当时为你想要做的事制定了一个模型。你做了很多事情。但在某种程度上，你突然遇到了世界上的某些方面，而这些是你从未为之准备过的，于是你发现自己卡壳了？
I think very often what a lot of us, myself, certainly included, have done, is we have this goal in mind. If I just get to there, all will be well. I call the all will be well system. Once I am happily married to two kids and have my own business, all will be well. Once I have an important job in an advanced energy technology company getting us off the oil problem, all will be well. You know, once everybody knows how to use a man. house, all will be well. And it turns out all isn't well. I mean, there's not a different you waiting on the other side of that finish line. There's not a different universe you're suddenly living in. There's not a different psyche suddenly saying, oh, now I feel like I'm really being
我认为很多时候，我们中的许多人——当然也包括我自己——所做的事情是，我们脑海里都有这样一个目标：只要我到了那个地方，一切都会好起来的。我称之为“一切都会好起来”系统。一旦我结婚生了两个孩子并拥有了自己的事业，一切都会好起来。一旦我在一家先进的能源技术公司找到一份重要的工作，帮我们摆脱石油危机，一切都会好起来。你知道的，一旦每个人都知道怎么使用鼠标，一切都会好起来。事实证明，一切并没有好起来。我的意思是，在那个终点线的另一端，并没有另一个更好的你在等待。你并非突然生活在另一个宇宙中。也没有另一个心理状态突然对你说：哦，现在我觉得我真正成为了
my true self. None of those things are caused by hitting those objectives. There are some questions that can keep us up at night. What is the meaning of life? What should I do with mine? These are big, juicy questions, and we can spend lifetimes thinking about them. But are they useful questions? When we come back, what we can learn about designing our lives from people who design products for a living? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
真实的自己。所有这些事情都不会因为实现了这些目标而发生。有些问题可以让我们彻夜难眠。生命的意义是什么？我应该用它来做什么？这些都是宏大而有趣的问题，我们可以花一辈子去思考它们。但它们是有用的问题吗？当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何从以设计产品为生的人身上，学习如何设计我们的人生。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
We all want to live meaningful lives, but sometimes the way we go about doing it can be counterproductive. In our pursuit of meaning, we can push ourselves into cycles of rumination, and self-doubt, or chronic stress and exhaustion. At Stanford University, Dave Evans says there are a handful of dysfunctional beliefs that get in the way of living the lives we want to live. Dave, I want to talk about some of these dysfunctional beliefs. You talked earlier about wanting to solve the energy crisis in the late 70s, getting a master's degree in thermoscience and then not being able to find work.
我们都想过有意义的生活，但有时候我们寻找意义的方式可能会适得其反。在追求意义的过程中，我们可能会让自己陷入反刍思维、自我怀疑、或者长期的压力和精疲力竭之中。在斯坦福大学，戴夫·埃文斯表示，有少数几种功能失调的信念阻碍了我们过上想要的生活。戴夫，我想谈谈其中一些功能失调的信念。你之前谈到在70年代末想要解决能源危机，获得了热科学硕士学位，随后却找不到工作。
You once met a man whom you call Alan, who had a similar story. I understand he started out in sociology, but then made a try to do. transition into the tech world? Yes, well, he was trying to make a living. He studied sociology and minored in art history, and he was a lovely guy with a nice liberal arts education, and, you know, it's hard to get paid for that. But he turned out to be a pretty good quantifier as well. He kind of liked spreadsheets and even statistics a little bit, and he found his way to doing project management, managing schedules and resources, that sort of thing. In software companies, particularly related to the way they ran their marketing program. So he ended up becoming a pretty much.
你曾经遇到过一个你称为艾伦的人，他有着类似的经历。据我所知，他最初学的是社会学，但后来试图转型进入科技界？是的，嗯，他当时只是想谋生。他学的是社会学，辅修艺术史，他是个可爱的人，受过很好的文科教育，而且，你知道的，很难靠这个赚钱。但他后来发现自己也很擅长量化分析。他有点喜欢电子表格，甚至对统计学也略知一二，他找到了做项目管理的路子，管理时间表和资源之类的。在软件公司里，特别是与他们营销项目运营方式相关的领域。所以他最终基本上成了一个
well-respected marketing project manager. So he's working on these large engineering teams. He's working on multi-million dollar projects. He's making good money. Was he feeling on top of the world? No, he was feeling he was feeling underutilized and he was feeling under-recognized. Because what he wanted was the chance to demonstrate some creativity. And so again, he's in a service role.
备受尊敬的营销项目经理。所以他在这些大型工程团队里工作。他从事着数百万美元的项目。他赚着不错的薪水。他觉得自己正处于世界之巅吗？没有，他觉得自己没有得到充分的利用，也没有得到应有的认可。因为他想要的是展现创造力的机会。所以同样地，他处于一个服务型的角色。
His clients, if you will, are internal people who work for the same company. And they would come to him with, can you help us with this? And we have this project, can you help us? And that was his job, which he did well. And then he would have ideas about how he could do it better, do it more creatively. And more often than not only were people not interested, they didn't even want to hear about it. Like, whatever. I mean, where's that thing?
如果可以这么说的话，他的客户是为同一家公司工作的内部员工。他们会带着这样的请求来找他：你能帮我们处理这个吗？我们有个项目，你能帮帮忙吗？这就是他的工作，他干得很出色。然后他会有关于如何做得更好、如何更有创意地完成工作的想法。然而往往不仅人们不感兴趣，甚至根本不想听。比如，随便吧。我的意思是，那个东西在哪儿？
I mean, I ordered, you know, a hamburger with no cheese on it. You know, I don't know what this sausage thing is, but where's my hamburger? Right. And he was pretty heartbroken. And his conclusion was that they don't value me. I'm not valued. These people don't understand what I can do. And so I can't be here.
我的意思是，我点了一个不要奶酪的汉堡。你知道的，我不知道这个香肠是怎么回事，但我的汉堡呢？没错。他感到非常心碎。他的结论是，他们不重视我。我不被重视。这些人根本不明白我能做什么。所以我不能呆在这儿。
So I think many of us have felt this way at some point. We get the thing that we think will fulfill us, the dream job, the house, perhaps even the perfect family. But we still feel like something is missing. You argue that this frustration stems from the fact that we put too much stock in two concepts, fulfillment and impact. Let's start with fulfillment. what do you mean when you say that we put too much talk in fulfillment? Well, this is really kind of why we wrote this most recent book. I mean, we'd help people design a lot of lives and redesign a lot of careers.
所以我想我们许多人在某个时刻都有过这种感受。我们得到了我们认为能让自己满足的东西——梦想中的工作、房子，甚至可能是完美的家庭。但我们仍然觉得缺了点什么。你认为，这种挫折感源于我们对两个概念寄予了过多的期望：充实感和影响力。让我们从充实感开始。当我们说对充实感寄予太多期望时，你是什么意思？嗯，这其实正是我们写这本最新书的原因。我的意思是，我们曾帮助人们设计了许多人生，也重新设计了许多职业。
And they still kept coming back going. I did all that. And technically it worked, but it's still not as fulfilling as I was hoping it was going to be. And we said, well, tell us what you mean by that. And overwhelmingly what fulfillment meant to people was, am I getting to be all that I can be? And then we did some research and found out the reason almost everybody thinks that fulfillment is, you know, getting a chance to do everything you want to do or particularly everything you can do is because Abraham Maslow told you that's what you should want. So we have a hierarchy
而他们仍然不断回来反馈说：我都照做了。技术上行得通，但它仍然没有我期望的那么充实。我们问：那跟我们说说你这话是什么意思。而对人们来说，充实感绝大多数意味着：我是否正在成为我所能成为的一切？然后我们做了一些研究，发现几乎每个人都认为充实感就是，你知道的，有机会去做你想做的一切，尤其是你能做的一切，这是因为亚伯拉罕·马斯洛告诉你这应该是你想要的。所以我们有一个需求层次
of needs going back to his originating paper in 1943, which the NIH calls one of the stickiest ideas on the social sciences, where the apex of the human experience is self-actualization. And self-actualization occurs when one becomes all that one can be. And if I can pull that off, what will I get, according to Maslow, is I will get fulfillment. So self-actualize, be everything you can be, and you get fulfillment. We know all of us contain more aliveness than your lifetime permit you to live out. There's more than one life worth of living in you in there. There's more than one of you.
理论，可以追溯到他1943年的原创论文，美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）称其为社会科学中最顽固的想法之一，人类体验的巅峰是自我实现。而当一个人成为他所能成为的一切时，自我实现就会发生。如果我能做到这一点，根据马斯洛的说法，我会得到什么？我会得到充实感。所以，去实现自我，成为你能成为的一切，你就能获得充实感。我们都知道，我们每个人体内蕴含的生命力，都远超你的一生所能展现的极限。你体内有不止一种值得过的人生。你体内有不止一个自己。
There's lots of chakers. Which one are you going to be this year? So once I know, and I accept the good news, wow, isn't it cool that my human capacity even exceeds my lifetime, which means I've got some alternative choice. to make, I've got some variety in front of me, oh, I no longer have the goal of trying to be all I can be, because you can't even get there from here. You can't be all you can be. Don't worry about that. Now, can I be fully who I'm trying to be right now? That's the invitation.
有很多个尚卡尔。你今年打算当哪一个呢？所以一旦我知道并接受了这个好消息——哇，人类的潜能竟然超越了我的生命长度，这不是很酷吗？这意味着我有一些替代选择可以做出，我的面前有各种各样的可能性，哦，我不再把“竭尽全力成为我所能成为的一切”作为目标了，因为你从这里根本到达不了那里。你无法成为你能成为的一切。别担心这个了。现在，我能完全做回我此刻正努力成为的那个人吗？这就是邀请所在。
So in some ways, what Maslow was telling us is that if you are everything that you want to be, if you can become everything that you possibly can be, you're going to be happy. But the point that you're is there are more lifetimes in each of us than we can fit into any one lifetime. And so by definition, none of us are actually going to reach that point of fulfillment. Yeah, so unfortunately, Maslow gave everybody this moral incentive to believe I deserve to be all that I can be. And our argument is that's impossible. The other idea you think can lead us to dysfunctional outcomes is this idea of impact. As people reach for fulfillment, they often ask themselves, how will I,
所以在某种程度上，马斯洛告诉我们的是，如果你成为了你想成为的一切，如果你能成为你可能成为的一切，你就会快乐。但你的观点是，我们每个人体内都有比我们能塞进任何一单一生命中更多的生命历程。因此，根据定义，我们实际上谁也无法达到那个充实感的顶峰。是的，不幸的是，马斯洛给了所有人一种道德激励，让他们相信“我理应成为我所能成为的一切”。而我们的论点是，这是不可能的。你认为会导致我们走向功能失调结果的另一个概念是“影响力”这个想法。当人们追求充实感时，他们经常会问自己：我将如何
fulfill my destiny. Can you talk about how this relates to the idea of impact, Dave? So some people start with, it's not fulfilling enough, and that's, am I getting to express all of me? And the other most common is, you know, it's just not meaningful enough. Well, what would make it more meaningful? Making a difference. I need to make a difference. I need to change the world. They need to have an impact. I need this to be recognized. I need this to last. And they're talking in a variety of ways all about the production of their lives, the product, the outcome of their work making some kind of a difference. Now, don't get us wrong. We are terribly in favor of people having positive impacts. I'm still trying to have a positive impact. But what we're noticing
实现我的命运。戴夫，你能谈谈这与影响力的概念有什么关系吗？所以有些人开始时会觉得，这还不够充实，也就是：我有没有表达出全部的自己？而另一个最常见的说法是，你知道的，这还不够有意义。嗯，什么能让它更有意义？产生影响。我需要产生影响。我需要改变世界。我需要产生影响力。我需要获得认可。我需要让这一切持久。他们以各种方式，全都在谈论他们生活的产物、产品、他们的工作成果所带来的某种改变。现在，别误会我们的意思。我们非常支持人们产生积极的影响。我仍然在努力产生积极的影响。但我们注意到的是
is for a lot of people, impact making is the only version of meaning making that they validate. And the problem with it is when you lean into that, even if it works. And by the way, if you do everything right, your chance of still successfully having an impact is maybe 50-50 because you know those other eight billion people on the planet, they might go off script at some point, and they're awfully hard to control. But, you know, even if you do pull off that impact, well, what have you done for me lately? Yeah. You know, I mean, you know, I shift the mouse a long time ago. What have you done for us lately? So impact, the feeling that comes from an impact doesn't last. And frankly, most of the time, pulling off having an impact doesn't work. So it's a very risky business to
对很多人来说，产生影响是他们唯一认可的创造意义的方式。而问题在于，当你倾心于这一点时，即使它成功了。顺便说一句，如果你把一切都做对了，你成功产生影响的概率也许也就一半一半，因为你知道地球上那另外八亿人，他们随时可能不按剧本演，而且他们实在太难控制了。但是，你知道的，即使你真的做到了产生影响，好吧，你最近为我做过什么？是的。你知道的，我的意思是，我很久以前推出了鼠标。你最近为我们做过什么？所以影响力，由影响力带来的感觉并不持久。坦率地说，大多数时候，产生影响根本行不通。所以决定这是我的生活有意义的唯一途径，是一件风险极高的事。
decide that's the only way my life is meaningful. So in some ways, we've hitched. So in some ways, we've hitched our wagons to these two horses, fulfillment and impact. And in some ways, they're both mirages. Yeah. And even for some people who are pulling it off, I've got friends my age starting their seventh company. You know, look at this. Anna, why are you doing this again?
所以在某种程度上，我们已经把。所以在某种程度上，我们把我们的马车套在了这两匹马上：充实感和影响力。在某种程度上，它们都是海市蜃楼。是的。甚至对于一些正在成功实现这一点的人来说，我有几个同龄的朋友正在创办他们的第七家公司。你看这个。安娜，你为什么又要这么做？
Well, I'm really good at it. Well, I know, but we knew that five companies ago. I mean, don't you have another idea yet? And frankly, what they are is they're so stuck on pulling off that impact thing, they've become addicted to it and they can't let go. And then when they finally get to the place where they can't do it anymore, it's an existential crisis. Let's look at another dysfunctional belief that gets in the way of living a meaningful life, Dave. Many of us feel stuck in one way or another.
嗯，我很擅长这个。嗯，我知道，但我们在五家公司前就知道这事了。我的意思是，你难道还没有别的想法吗？坦率地说，他们之所以这样，是因为他们太执着于实现那种影响力，以至于对它上了瘾，无法放手。然后当他们最终到达再也无法做到这一点的地步时，就会陷入存在主义危机。戴夫，让我们来看看阻碍过上有意义生活的另一种功能失调的信念。我们许多人都以这样或那样的方式感到卡壳了。
We're not sure why or what to do. Some people call it a midlife crisis or I've even heard the term quarter life crisis now. Your colleague Bill Burnett once had a student that you call Sonia. Sonia had a problem. What was this problem? Well, she too had, you know, she was working in high technology, and she went to a great big company, and she was writing code. And she was one of these successful people, the stuff she's writing millions, even billions of people are using. And she's making a good living. She's working with really intelligent people.
我们不确定原因，也不知道该怎么办。有些人称之为中年危机，或者我现在甚至听过“四分之一人生危机”这个词。你的同事比尔·伯内特曾有一个学生，你称她为索尼娅。索尼娅遇到了一个问题。这个问题是什么？嗯，她也有过，你知道的，她曾在高科技行业工作，去了一家非常大的公司写代码。她是那种成功人士之一，她写的东西有几百万甚至数十亿人在使用。她过着不错的生活。她和非常聪明的人一起工作。
She's growing and learning new things. Wow, this is working on every front. Except then, you know, she suddenly realized, I'm just turning the crank. You know, I'm part of the. this mechanism of high technology, you know, having people click things through and look at another website, does that really matter to me? And am I stuck on this thing forever? And, I mean, she was in her early 20s and already felt like she was not hitting the ceiling. She was hitting the wall because she kind of looked forward through the lens of, you know, techno-capitalism and said,
她在成长并学习新的东西。哇，这在各方面都很管用。除了那时，你知道的，她突然意识到：我只是在机械地转动齿轮。你知道的，我是高科技这个机器的一部分，你知道的，让人们点击东西并浏览另一个网站，这真的对我很重要吗？我会被困在这件事上直到永远吗？我的意思是，她才20出头，就已经觉得自己撞到的不是天花板，而是墙壁了，因为她透过技术资本主义的镜头向前眺望，然后说，
that's all this thing is forever. Talk about the idea, Dave, that when we are feeling stuck and desperate like this, many of us look for a single big solution that can get us unstuck. You know, there's this magical idea that there is this one place I really deserve to be, my special calling, my special place in the world, what is the universe inviting me to do, or where is my passion, all these different narratives come around. There's this, there's this lovely idea that I will find it, which either has no compromise or just tiny little compromises and really lights up the dashboard of my soul and makes me feel like I am in the right place doing the right thing. This is what I was made for. And then and then only do I deserve to be happy and
这永远就是这玩意的全部了。戴夫，谈谈这种想法：当我们感到被困住且绝望时，我们许多人会寻找一个能让我们摆脱困境的单一宏大解决方案。你知道的，有一种神奇的想法，认为存在这样一个我真正配得上的地方，我的特殊使命，我在世界上的特殊位置，宇宙正在召唤我去做的事，或者我的热情所在，所有这些不同的叙事纷至沓来。有一种非常美好的想法，认为我会找到它，它要么毫无妥协，要么只有微不足道的妥协，并且真正点亮我心灵的仪表盘，让我觉得我在正确的地方做着正确的事。这就是我为之诞生的。然后——也只有在那时——我才配得上快乐，
feel like I'm being my authentic self? And that almost never really happens. I understand that Sonia did this. She basically decided that she was going to make a radical change in this career that she was unhappy with. Yeah, she really wanted to make a jump. And she was particularly attracted to something radically different because I really wanted to feel different. And a number of her friends were in the process of going up to the San Juan Islands and jumping into working together and revitalizing an old farm and making it an organic farm. So maybe I can just go back to the land and have a personal experience and join this commune of organic farmers. And that's what's really going to work for me. We don't really know how that all worked out for her, but there's a very similar story. Another young man, I know,
并觉得自己正在做真实的自己？而这几乎从来没有真正发生过。我听说索尼娅就是这么做的。她基本上决定在她这个她感到不快乐的职业生涯中做出激进的改变。是的，她真的很想跳槽。她特别被某些彻底不同的东西所吸引，因为我真的想体验不同的感觉。她的几个朋友正在前往圣胡安群岛，并投身于共同生活、复兴一个旧农场并将其改造成有机农场。所以也许我可以回归土地，获得个人体验，加入这个有机农场主的公社。这才是真正适合我的。我们并不知道这一切对她来说结果如何，但有一个非常相似的故事。我认识的另一个年轻人，
who was highly successful in high technology stopped. and went to try to start an artist commune. Actually bought a property in a rural area, brought artists in, like, we're going to have this creative environment. It's going to be great. And did that for about two years. And then that was lovely.
他在高科技领域取得了巨大的成功，却停了下来。转而去尝试创办一个艺术家公社。实际上在农村地区买了一块地，把艺术家们请来，心想：我们要创造这个富有创意的环境。这会很棒的。并坚持做了大约两年。然后那曾经很美好。
And then to realize, all it is is radically different. I don't even really like this. This isn't that interesting. At the end of the day, these people are kind of boring because all they want to talk about is this one little narrow view about art. And what I fell for was the radical shift. And radical shifts are radical. But that radicalism doesn't.
然后她意识到，这一切不过是“彻底的不同”罢了。我甚至根本不怎么喜欢这个。这其实没那么有趣。到头来，这些人有点无聊，因为他们整天想谈论的只有关于艺术的那个狭隘观点。而我当时迷恋的是激进的转变。激进的转变确实是激进的。但那种激进主义
last very long, and you're still stuck with waking up being you, living in the world, is this the life I want to be in? Let's look at another dysfunctional belief that gets in the way of our happiness. This one is about the idea that if we don't feel good about doing what we're doing, the solution is to double down, work harder and grind. Now, of course, there is a vast amount of research that finds that hard work is strongly correlated with success, but I want to talk about the misguided idea we have that more is always better. Can you talk about your own life choices here, Dave?
持续不了多久，你依然得面对醒来后的自己，在这个世界上生活：这真的是我想过的生活吗？让我们来看看阻碍我们幸福的另一种功能失调的信念。这个信念关于这样一种想法：如果我们对正在做的事情感觉不好，解决办法就是加倍努力、更拼命地工作并死扛。当然，有大量的研究发现，努力工作与成功有着强烈的关联，但我想要讨论的是我们那种“越多越好”的错误观念。戴夫，你能谈谈你在这里的人生选择吗？
When your first kid was born, you are, you know, I don't know how to put this kindly. You were a workaholic. Yeah, you know, it really is, well, if this is good, more is better. You know, the psychologist called this hedonic treadmill. This is how addiction works, you know, how much is enough, a little bit more. And so what I was trying to do was trying to be a successful business person. So I was growing rapidly and getting more responsibility. And, you know, having one kid is a good idea.
当你的第一个孩子出生时，你——嗯，我不知道该怎么客气地说。你是个工作狂。是的，你知道的，这其实就是，如果这个很好，那么更多就会更好。你知道的，心理学家称之为“享乐适应 treadmill”。这就是瘾是如何起作用的，你知道的，多少才算够，再多一点。所以我当时试图做的是成为一个成功的商业人士。所以我成长迅速，承担了更多的责任。而且，你知道的，生一个孩子是个好主意。
Let's have more. So by this time, I've got three kids, you know, and I've got, so I've got twice as big a family and about five times as big a job. And, of course, my obligation just to do everything well, and I'm not. It takes me about 75 hours a week to do that job. I learned how to operate on three to four hours of sleep a night, which was a bit of a disaster. And then I had a severe comeuppance one Saturday morning, about nine o'clock. I'm sitting in the family room, drinking a cup of coffee. and I heard my then three-year-old son, Robbie, say to his mother,
再生几个吧。所以到这个时候，我有三个孩子，你知道的，所以我的家庭规模扩大了一倍，工作规模扩大了大约五倍。当然，我把一切都做好的义务也在增加，而我并没有做好。我每周花大约75个小时来做那份工作。我学会了每晚只睡三到四个小时来运转，这有点像场灾难。然后我在一个星期六的早上遭遇了一次沉重的打击，大约九点钟。我坐在家庭房里，喝着一杯咖啡。我听到我当时三岁的儿子罗比对他的妈妈说：
Mom, could we play with Dad today? Or are he just going to fall asleep in the chair again? Wow. And I went, oh, my God. When I was Robbie's age, my dad was gone because he died. When Robbie's Robbie's age, his dad's gone because he's asleep. You know, a corpse, a sleeping guy, about the same thing. And I suddenly had this epiphany.
妈妈，我们今天能和爸爸一起玩吗？还是他又要在椅子上睡着了？哇。然后我说，哦，天哪。当我像罗比这么大的时候，我爸爸已经不在了，因为他去世了。当罗比像他现在这么大时，他的爸爸不在了，因为他在睡觉。你知道的，一具尸体和一个睡着的人，差不多是一回事。我突然顿悟了。
Oh, my God, I've got to fix this. It's not working. working. More is not working. You know, we had lighty clots on Hidden Brain some years ago, and that episode has stuck with me ever since. And his thesis is that whenever we're trying to do something in our lives, our instinctive approach is always to add, to do something more, to increase what we're doing, to add the extra note in a score of music, to add the extra ingredient in a dish that we're cooking, to always think of addition rather than subtraction.
哦，天哪，我必须解决这个问题。这行不通。行不通。盲目增加更多是行不通的。你知道的，几年前我们在“隐藏的大脑”里采访过莱迪·克洛茨（Leidy Klotz），那期节目从那以后一直印在我的脑海里。他的核心论点是，每当我们在生活中试图做成某事时，我们的直觉做法总是做加法，做更多的事情，增加我们正在做的事情，在乐谱里多加一个音符，在我们烹饪的菜肴里多加一种配料，总是去想做加法而不是做减法。
Whereas very often, it is subtraction that gets us to the person and the place we want to be. It is indeed. Georgia O'Keeffe, an artist that it's in elimination that things become available. The biggest decision you make is an artist is to decide what not to include. It's about getting more out of. In fact, probably the life you're already in is full of more meaning-making, full of more aliveness. If you have the tricks that wherewithal, in particular the mindsets, necessary, to see it, to attend to it, and to get it from it.
然而很多时候，正是做减法才让我们成为了我们想成为的人，来到了我们想去的地方。确实如此。乔治亚·奥基夫，一位艺术家曾说，正是在消除中，事物才变得触手可及。作为艺术家，你做出的最大决定是决定不包含什么。这是关于从中获得更多。事实上，也许你已经身处的生活充满了更多意义的创造，充满了更多的生命力。如果你具备相应的技巧和财力，特别是必要的心态去看到它、关注它并从中获益的话。
So we really want to free people up. We want people to be free to get what's already there. The poet Mary Oliver famously asked, what is it you plan to do with your one wild and precious life? It's a wonderful question. It can prompt us to dream big to ask if our ambitions are equal to our potential. But it's also the kind of question that can make us feel that whatever we do is not enough. If one lifetime cannot contain all that we can do,
所以我们真的想解放人们。我们希望人们能够自由地获取那些已经存在的东西。诗人玛丽·奥利弗曾有一句名言：你打算如何使用你这野生而宝贵的一生？这是一个美妙的问题。它能促使我们胸怀大志，去审视我们的雄心是否配得上我们的潜能。但它也是那种会让我们觉得无论做什么都还不够的问题。如果一个生命无法容纳我们所能做的一切，
surely our hopes and dreams will always be far greater than our accomplishments. Doesn't that set us up for a lifetime of feeling like we are not measuring up, not doing enough? For a lifetime of unhappiness? When we come back, how to root our dreams and ambitions in the soil of what is possible. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you ever felt stuck in life, even when you are doing work that was important and useful?
我们的希望和梦想肯定永远会远远大于我们的成就。这难道不会让我们陷入一种终生觉得自愧不如、做得不够的生活吗？陷入终生的不快乐吗？当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何将我们的梦想和 ambitions 扎根于“可能”的土壤中。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你是否曾在生活中感到被困住，哪怕你当时做的工作既重要又有用？
If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Send the audio file to us using the email address, Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, stuck. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. We all make plans, set goals, and chase after what we believe will bring us happiness.
如果你有一个愿意与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。使用电子邮件地址将音频文件发送给我们：Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行：stuck（困境）。再次强调，邮箱是 Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。我们都制定计划、设定目标，并追逐那些我们相信能带来幸福的东西。
But then, almost inevitably, things don't go the way we expect. Life doesn't work out the way we imagined. What if the problem isn't us, or even the vagaries of life, but the way we are approaching our goals? Dave Evans is co-author with Bill Burnett of how to live a meaningful life, using design thinking to unlock purpose, joy and flow every day. He argues that thinking like a designer can help us establish the foundations of a good life. Dave, you've taught design thinking for many years. You've come on the show before to talk about this idea.
但随后，几乎不可避免地，事情并没有按我们预期的方式发展。生活并没有像我们想象的那样运转。如果问题不在于我们，甚至不在于生活的多变，而在于我们接近目标的方式呢？戴夫·埃文斯与比尔·伯内特合著了《如何过上有意义的生活：运用设计思维每天解锁目标、快乐和心流》。他认为，像设计师一样思考可以帮助我们建立美好生活的基础。戴夫，你教设计思维很多年了。你以前来过节目谈论这个想法。
For listeners who are not familiar with this approach, what is design thinking? Well, design thinking is, first of all, the relatively new, about 15 or 20-year-old nominclature, the name we have for a process that was originally conceived at Stanford going back to 1963 called Human-Centered. design, HCD. We renamed it design thinking about 20 years ago. It makes it a little more accessible, more accurate, really. And all it is is a methodology to innovatively come up with ideas and solutions to problems that are not easily solved. Problems where you don't know what you're looking for until you find it. And when you find it, it's so unique to the context and the person's involved. It's not replicatable. And it changes over time. And so design thinking is an
对于不熟悉这种方法的听众来说，什么是设计思维？嗯，设计思维首先是一个相对较新的术语，大约有15到20年的历史，这是我们为一个最初在1963年斯坦福构思、被称为“以人为本的设计”（HCD）的过程起的名字。我们大约在20年将其重新命名为设计思维。这让它变得更容易接触，也更准确。而它所代表的只是一种方法论，旨在创新性地提出想法和解决方案，去解决那些不易解决的问题。那些在你找到答案之前不知道自己在找什么的问。而当你找到它时，它是如此独特于具体的情境和所涉及的人。它是不可复制的。而且它会随着时间而改变。所以设计思维是一种
approach two, number one, understanding the problem you're working on and what you might try to do about it. And then having ideas that turn into prototypes, experiments to learn your way forward and see what might actually work. And then you can implement something that actually is feasible. So what Bill and I did starting 20 years ago is we took those ideas about designing a future thing you've never done before into designing ourselves, not just designing products. And that's turned out to be a pretty interesting conversation. Hmm. So one of the imperatives of design thinking is to grapple with problems at the right scale. So when we ask ourselves, what is the meaning of life? You say that could be an interesting question,
方法，首先，理解你正在处理的问题以及你可能会尝试做什么。然后产生能够转化为原型的想法，也就是通过实验来摸索前行，看看什么可能真正起作用。然后你可以实施一些切实可行的方案。所以比尔和我从20年前开始做的，就是把那些关于设计一个你从未做过的未来事物的想法，应用到设计我们自己身上，而不仅仅是设计产品。事实证明，这变成了一场非常有趣的对话。嗯。所以设计思维的命令之一，就是要在正确的规模上处理问题。因此，当我们问自己“生命的意义是什么”时，你说这可能是一个有趣的问题，
but that might be a very bad design question. Can you explain why? Yeah, we say problem finding precedes problem solving. And one of the reasons many efforts fail is you're working on the wrong thing. Very often you're working on a too big thing or the wrong thing. And so trying to answer, that one ultimate existential question, what is the meaning of my life? What will I be able to say on my deathbed and be satisfied with? That is a really tall bar. And frankly, we don't know how to design for that because it takes the whole life to answer it. So we like working on answerable, doable problems. And the better question is not what's the meaning of life, but how might I live a more meaningful life now? And that's what we're trying to help people do.
但这可能是一个非常糟糕的设计问题。你能解释一下为什么吗？是的，我们说“发现问题先于解决问题”。许多努力失败的原因之一，就是你正在处理错误的事情。很多时候，你处理的事情要么太宏大，要么就不对。因此，试图回答那个终极的存在主义问题：我生命的意义是什么？我在临终时能说些什么并感到满意？那是一个非常高的标准。坦率地说，我们不知道该如何为此进行设计，因为这需要用一生的时间来回答。所以我们喜欢处理那些可回答的、可执行的问题。更好的问题不是“生命的意义是什么”，而是“我如何能在现在过上更有意义的生活？”而这正是我们试图帮助人们去做的。
Let's talk about some of the ways that design thinking can make the question of life's meaningfulness more achievable, more doable. You point to a number of different design principles that can help break down this question. The first is something that you call fully engaged and calmly detached. What do you mean by this, Dave? What does it mean they have the mind of a designer? Designers who think this way look at the world a little bit differently. So fully engaged and calmly detached is this aspirational mindset that says, I want to be entirely available, entirely engaged with what I'm doing that's right in front.
让我们谈谈设计思维能够让“生命是否有意义”这个问题变得更可实现、更可执行的一些方式。你指出了许多不同的设计原则，它们可以帮助分解这个问题。首先是被称为“全情投入且冷静超然”的概念。戴夫，你这是什么意思？拥有设计师的心态意味着什么？以这种方式思考的设计师对世界的看法略有不同。所以，“全情投入且冷静超然”是一种令人向往的心态，意思是：我希望完全投入、完全参与到我眼前正在做的事情中去。
I'm having a conversation with this incredibly lovely person named Shangra Vedantam on this fabulous conversation called Hidden Brain with a bunch of thoughtful people. Am I paying attention? Or am I thinking about what I'm going to have with dinner or my friend who's staying over at the house tonight? So I want to be fully engaged, but I also want to be calmly detached. Because there's this thing called the outcome of what I'm doing that in truth, I have no control over. at the end of the day, doing the right thing is all I can do the best I can possibly do. So I can control my participation, but I cannot control the outcome.
我和一位极其可爱的嘉宾香卡·维丹塔姆（Shangra Vedantam）在一个名为“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain）的精彩节目中与一群思索深刻的人交谈。我是在专心听吗？还是在想晚餐吃什么，或者今晚要在家里过夜的朋友？所以，我既想全身心投入，又想保持冷静的超然。因为我正在做的事情有一个所谓的结果，说实话，这是我无法控制的。归根结底，做正确的事就是我所能做的全部，也是我能做到极致的事。因此，我可以掌控自己的参与度，但我无法掌控结果。
And it turns out those two things then become competitors. If I get too wound up in worrying about the out, is this going to go well? Is Shanker going to like the episode? I wonder what the listeners will think. If I'm too distracted by my involvement in the outcome, I'm too attached to that outcome. It's going to get in the way of my participation. So the best way to be fully engaged is to let go the outcome, and then we'll take things as they come.
结果证明，这两件事随后成了竞争对手。如果我过度纠结于结果，事情会顺利吗？香卡会喜欢这一集吗？听众会怎么想？如果我被对结果的关注分心了，对那个结果过于执着，它就会妨碍我的参与。所以，全身心投入的最佳方式就是放手结果，然后兵来将挡，水来土掩。
And of course, this happens at an interpersonal level all the time. Someone gives us feedback. The feedback is critical, and instead of listening to it or exploring it with curiosity, we get defensive because we now are saying someone is criticizing what I'm doing, someone doesn't like the outcomes of what I'm doing, I'm working so hard, I'm a good person. and now suddenly your ego gets caught up with the problem, and now you can't listen to the advice for what it actually is. Being all committed to the outcome that you have in mind,
当然，这种情况在人际交往中时时刻刻都在发生。有人给我们反馈。反馈是批判性的，我们没有去倾听或带着好奇心去探索，反而开启了防御模式，因为我们现在觉得有人在批评我的所作所为，有人不喜欢我所做事情的结果，我工作那么努力，我是个好人。而现在，你的自我突然被卷入了这个问题，导致你无法听取建议的真实本意。全心执着于你脑海中的那个结果，
frankly, completely takes you out of what you're already doing. It's not that I don't care. It's that I'm not so committed to it and involved to it that I now am staking my reputation on it, and I'm staking my identity, and now I've got a psychological attachment to it, and it's all about me. So what it really boils down to is
坦白说，会彻底让你脱离你正在做的事情。这并不是说我不在乎。而是说我没有那么执着、那么深陷其中，以至于现在把我的声誉和身份都押在上面，我对它产生了一种心理上的执念，一切都成了关于“我”的事。所以，归根结底其实就是
recognizing that it's not about you all the time. Many years ago, the researcher Ron Howard talked about the quality of the decision versus the quality of the outcome. And in some ways, that has bearing on what we've been just talking about, Dave. Can you explain this idea? It turns out thinking well, making a good decision, is a good idea. And if we could run the same decision in a thousand parallel universes and watch all the vagaries, you know, the better decisions would probably work out more
认识到事情并不总是关于你。多年前，研究人员罗恩·霍华德（Ron Howard）谈到了决策的质量与结果的质量。在某种程度上，这与我们刚才讨论的内容有关，戴夫。你能解释一下这个观点吗？事实证明，深思熟虑、做出正确的决定是个好主意。如果我们能在成千上万个平行宇宙中执行同一个决定，观察所有的变数，你知道，更好的决定可能会比糟糕的决定
often than the bad decisions, but let's be clear, I'm not in charge of the future. You can influence as best you possibly can, but let's let's have an honest and humble perspective on ourselves. I'm doing the best I can, but that doesn't mean it's going to work. So in some ways, what I'm hearing you say is that when it comes to the outcome of our decisions, you know, acknowledging them with some humility means that, you know, I can plan for a beautiful wedding, but I might want to tell myself, you know, it could rain that day. The caterers might get a flat tire on their way to the venue. The venue itself might burn to the ground. There are many things that are outside my control and acknowledging them at the outset might, in some ways, limit my expectations and frustrations
带来更多好的结果，但我们要明白，我并不掌控未来。你可以尽最大努力去施加影响，但让我们对自身保持一种诚实而谦逊的视角。我在尽力而为，但这并不意味着它一定会成功。所以在某种程度上，我听到你所说的是，当谈到我们决策的结果时，带着一些谦逊去认可它们意味着，你知道，我可以规划一场完美的婚礼，但我可能想告诉自己，你知道，那天可能会下雨。餐饮服务商在去会场的路上可能会爆胎。会场本身可能会被大火烧毁。有许多事情是我无法控制的，在最初就承认这一点，在某种程度上可能会限制我的期望和挫折感，
when things don't go the way I want. Absolutely. What we're trying to do is I'm trying to give reality its best possible chance of turning out the way I hope. And then once I'm doing that, then I release the fact that then I get to fully participate in the reality that is actually going to occur. So if indeed I've planned this thing and it rains that day, well, I can spend all afternoon going, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, you know, and being mad at the weatherman who owed me a sunny afternoon, or just go, okay, and what can we do with this? You know, there's this phrase, making the best of a bad situation. That's really unfair.
当事情没有按我预期发展的时候。绝对是的。我们努力在做的，是让现实有最大可能按我希望的方向发展。一旦我做到了这一点，我就放下了对结果的执念，从而能够全身心地参与到即将实际发生的现实中去。所以，如果我确实计划好了这一切，而那天却下雨了，好吧，我可以一整个下午都在抱怨，糟了、糟了、糟了、糟了、糟了，你知道的，生那个欠我一个晴朗下午的气象预报员的气，或者只是说，好吧，我们能用这个做点什么呢？你知道，有这样一句话，化劣势为优势。这其实很不公平。
The situation doesn't think of itself as bad. The rain's not going, I'm here to ruin your party. you know, the rain's just falling. So it's really making the best of the situation. All we're ever trying to do is make the best of the situation. Another design principle you talk about is story crafting. What is story crafting, Dave? Well, there's the old line that life is a story we tell ourselves,
情况本身并不觉得糟糕。雨并不是在想：我是来毁了你的派对的。你知道的，雨只是在下雨。所以这实际上是“化当前情境为最好”。我们一直试图做的，只是充分利用当前的情境。你谈到的另一个设计原则是故事构筑（story crafting）。什么是故事构筑，戴夫？嗯，有句老话叫生活是我们对自己讲述的故事，
and the psychologist will remind us now that's true. Your internal narrative really matters. And so story crafting is about picking carefully the story that you are telling yourself and living into because it is a profound. effect, both on the life you live and the quality of your experience of it. Of course, that story has to be true. It can't be a fantasy story. We're not fans of magical thinking, but we are big fans of picking the story that's truest and most generative to give you the best possible chance of becoming fully alive. You and others have looked at the role that story crafting plays
心理学家现在会提醒我们，这是真的。你的内在叙事真的很重要。因此，故事构筑就是精心挑选你正在对自己讲述并融入其中的故事，因为它会产生深远的影响，不仅对你所过的生活，而且对你体验生活的质量。当然，这个故事必须是真实的。它不能是幻想故事。我们不是墨守成规或盲目乐观（magical thinking）的粉丝，但我们非常支持选择最真实、最具建设性的故事，为你提供成为全面鲜活的自己的最佳可能。你和其他人探讨过故事构筑所扮演的角色，
among first generation college students. Tell me about this work and what you find. Well, you know, Stanford is, of course, an elite university. But, you know, But what people lose track of is, you know, 80% of our students are on financial aid. So they're not prep school kids. And by no means, are they all highly resource. We have lots of first-generation students or under-resourced students who really suffer the imposter syndrome. Like, man, do I really belong here?
在第一代大学生中。跟我讲讲这项工作以及你的发现。嗯，你知道，斯坦福当然是一所顶尖大学。但是，你知道的，但人们忽略的是，你知道的，我们80%的学生都接受经济资助。所以他们不是预科学校的孩子。决不能说他们都拥有丰富的资源。我们有很多第一代大学生或资源匮乏的学生，他们真的遭受着冒名顶替综合征的困扰。比如，天哪，我真的属于这里吗？
And there are a group of people in the education school and psychology department who work on intervening in ways that it might be helpful to these students. And one of the results was, it turned out, as short as a 15-minute intervention, with a first-generation student on the narrative they're telling themselves can have a transformative effect that lasts not only all four years of college, but five or ten years after. And the narrative simply is not, yeah, you're under resource and all those guys who went to the prep school are going to kick your butt.
教育学院和心理学系有一群人在研究如何以对这些学生有帮助的方式进行干预。其中一个结果是，事实证明，只需对第一代大学生进行短短15分钟的干预，针对他们对自己讲述的叙事进行调整，就能产生变革性的影响，这种影响不仅能持续大学四年，还能持续毕业后五到十年。这种叙事很简单，不是说，是的，你资源匮乏，那些去过预科学校的人都会把你打趴下。
That story is then replaced by the reason you're here is you're highly capable. You can do this work, and there are lots of resources to help you that you can avail yourself of. And if that alternate narrative is offered to that first-gen student by another first-gen student two or three years older than them for whom it has worked, they believe it. And literally, that 15 minutes, their performance changes permanently. I want to talk about another design principle. But first, I want to talk about some of your own experience as a designer. When you were an undergraduate engineering student, Dave, you were also a firefighter.
那个故事被取而代之的是：你来这里的原因是你能力非凡，你能够完成这项工作，而且有很多资源可以帮助你，你可以充分利用它们。如果这种替代叙事是由一个比他们大两三年、且在类似干预下成功过的一代大学生传递给这位第一代学生的，他们就会相信。字面意义上，仅仅那15分钟，他们的表现就永久性地改变了。我想谈谈另一个设计原则。但首先，我想谈谈你作为一名设计师的一些亲身经历。当你是本科工程系学生时，戴夫，你还是一名消防员。
And one of the first products you designed was a fire hydrant wrench. What is a fire hydrant wrench? Well, if you ever take a look at your neighborhood fire hydrant, there's a little cover over the nozzle where the water comes out on one side. And on the other side of that thing, there's a little post sticking out. That's actually the valve that opens and closes the hydrant. And if you look at it, it's in the shape of a pentagon. It's in the shape of a five-sided pentagon.
你设计的第一批产品之一是消防栓扳手。什么是消防栓扳手？嗯，如果你曾经看你邻里周围的消防栓，在水流出的喷嘴一侧有一个小盖子。在那东西的另一侧，有一个凸起的小柱子。那其实是打开和关闭消防栓的阀门。如果你看一下，它是五角形的。它是一个五边形的形状。
And the reason is because we don't want people opening fire hydrants who don't know what you're doing. And so when I went into mechanical engineering and went into the PRL, the product realization lab, which you might call the machine shop, I walked in there with a great big chunk of brass. And the idea was to mill that thing into a fire hydrant wrench that had one of those pentagon things on it on the one hand and a kind of special curvy thing on the other to take the cover off because you need one of those if you're fighting a fire. Tell me what happened as you were trying to mold this brass thingy into a wrench. Did it all go smoothly? It went very unsmoothly, because I didn't know what I was doing. I'd never done anything like that before. I never used
原因是我们不希望不懂操作的人去打开消防栓。所以当我进入机械工程专业并进入PRL（产品实现实验室，你可以称之为机械车间）时，我带着一大块黄铜走了进去。当时的想法是将那东西铣削成一个消防栓扳手，一面有那种五角形结构，另一面则有一种特殊的弯曲形状，用来取下盖子，因为如果你在灭火，你需要其中一个。告诉我，当你试图把这个黄铜玩意儿塑造成一个扳手时发生了什么？一切都顺利吗？非常不顺利，因为我不知道自己在做什么。我以前从未做过那样的事情。我从来没有使用过
the machine, didn't know how to use a mill or a lathe or a high-speed, you know, metal band, so on. I'd never worked with anything that heavy before. I was completely inexperienced, you know, broke tools. I had to get more materials. And I had this idea in my head about this perfect wrench that I'd seen that was, you know, bought from a very expensive supplier. And then I finally realized what I was doing was, which is a metaphor for the rest of real life is, I'm trying to make a real thing. I'm trying to bring it into being. I'm trying to take something and allow something real, something finite, something limited, something constrained, something even with flaws in it, to come into being. And all that struggle with, you know, breaking parts and what have you,
这台机器，不知道怎么用铣床、车床或高速金属带锯等等。我以前从未处理过那么重的东西。我完全缺乏经验，你知道的，弄坏了工具。我不得不获取更多的材料。我脑子里有一个完美的扳手概念，那是我从一家非常昂贵的供应商那里看到的。然后我终于意识到我在做什么，这其实是现实生活中其他事情的一个隐喻：我正在试图制造一个真实的东西。我试图把它带入现实。我试图拿一样东西，让某种真实的东西、某种有限的、有约束力的、甚至带有瑕疵的东西变为现实。所有那些与弄坏零件等情况的斗争，
proved to me that this thing was going to be a compromise. You say that the way we craft physical objects can teach us something about how to craft and make meaningful moments out of the daily events of our lives. And you call this moment making. What do you mean by this term? Well, the thing about making anything is, of course, is limitation. And this goes back to one of our big reframes on the meaning question is what we call the scandal of particularity, which is there is no perfect fire hydrant wrench.
向我证明了这东西将是一个妥协。你说我们塑造物理对象的方式可以教给我们一些东西，关于如何塑造和创造我们日常生活中的有意义的时刻。你把这叫做“时刻创造”（moment making）。你这个词是什么意思？嗯，制作任何东西的特点，当然就是局限性。这可以追溯到我们关于意义问题的重大重新构架之一，也就是我们所说的“特殊性的丑闻”（scandal of particularity），即世上没有完美的消防栓扳手，
there is no perfect birthday cake. There is no perfect conversation with Chakra Vedantam. There's only the one I'm actually in. So thing one, in making something, is recognizing its limitation. All ultimates are only really found in the particular. And they reflect that. They're not the fullness of it,
没有完美的生日蛋糕。没有与香卡·维丹塔姆的完美谈话。只有我正身处其中的那一个。所以第一点，在制造某样东西时，是承认它的局限性。所有的终极意义其实都只能在特定之中找到。并且它们反映了这一点。它们不是它的全部，
but they reflect it honestly. And that isn't a problem. It's not, oh, I fell short again. It's not the perfect fire hydrant wrench. It's the real one. All the hours I spent making, this thing. It started a great big block of brass, and it ended up being a very specific thing, is it very much like sculpture, you know, like Michelangelo releasing the angel from the marble.
但它们诚实地反映了它。这并不是个问题。这不是“哦，我又没达到预期”。这不是完美的消防栓扳手。这是真正的扳手。我花在制造这东西上的所有时间。它始于一块巨大的黄铜，最终变成了一个非常具体的东西，这不是很像雕塑吗，你知道的，就像米开朗基罗把天使从大理石中释放出来一样。
I'm in the process of releasing the wrench from the block. And if all I want is the end result, then everything I did up to that simply doesn't matter. And every mistake I make is in the way and a problem, as opposed to, yes, I need to pay enough attention that this thing will actually work when it's all said and done, that matters. However, was I present at the time? Was I actually noticing and learning how to use the machine tools? Was I noticing how a sharpened tool works differently than a dull tool? Did I understand the difference between brass and steel? Did I get the feel that I actually feel, and you can't, if you do this right, you can feel the metal cutting in your hands, and do you understand that experience? And now I'm actually being a maker,
我正处于将扳手从石块中释放出来的过程中。如果我想要的只是最终结果，那么我在此之前做的一切就都毫无意义了。我犯的每一个错误都是绊脚石和问题，而不是——是的，我需要给予足够的关注，让这东西在尘埃落定后真正起作用，这很重要。然而，我在当时是在场的吗？我真的在注意并学习如何使用机床吗？我注意到锋利的工具与钝的工具有什么不同吗？我理解黄铜和钢的区别吗？我感受到了那种真实的触感吗——如果你做得对，你能感觉到金属在你的手中切割，你理解那种体验吗？现在我才真正成了一个创造者，
not just I completed making. And so if everything's just the outcome, when it's all done, by the second I finish making that wrench, how long does the moment of being done last? A microsecond? Now it's past. So what's next? And I missed the whole darn thing.
而不只是“我完成了制作”。所以，如果一切都只是结果，当这一切都完成后，自我完成那个扳手的那一秒算起，那种“完成”的时刻能持续多久？一微秒？现在它已经过去了。那么接下来是什么？我错过了整个该死的过程。
You know, people very often miss the whole darn thing because all they wanted was the outcome and then it's over. I mean, philosophers and spiritual traditions have told us for centuries that we have to live in the moment. And in some ways, that's what I hear you saying. It's exactly what we're saying. I mean, Ram Dass said it a long time ago, you know, be here now. Because at the end of the day, that's the essence of it. We call it the flow world, not the transaction rule.
你知道，人们经常错过整个该死的过程，因为他们想要的只是结果，然后一切就结束了。我的意思是，哲学家和精神传统几个世纪以来一直在告诉我们，我们必须活在当下。在某种程度上，这就是我听到你所表达的。这正是我们想说的。拉姆·达斯（Ram Dass）很久以前就说过，你知道，活在当下（be here now）。因为归根结底，这就是它的精髓。我们称之为流动世界（flow world），而不是交易规则（transaction rule）。
The transaction was, finish the wrench, make it available along the fire truck. That's a transaction. But the moment was standing at the lay, then actually experiencing how a cutting, tool and a piece of metal interact. That's entering into the fullness of the moment. So moment making turns out to be the critical task of people who want to design more meaning in their life, and particularly the kinds of meaning that can transcend not just impact making, which is wonderful but hard and short-lived. These moments full of potential meaningful experience abound in front of us. So the number one skill of a meaning-making designer is moment-making.
交易是：完成扳手，把它放在消防车上备用。那是一笔交易。但那个时刻是站在车床旁，实际体验切削工具和金属块是如何相互作用的。那是进入时刻的丰盈之中。因此，对于那些想要在生活中设计更多意义的人来说，时刻创造被证明是一项至关重要的任务，尤其是那种能够超越单纯的影响力创造的意义——影响力虽然美妙，但却艰难且短暂。这些充满潜在有意义体验的时刻在我们的面前俯拾即是。因此，意义创造设计师的第一技能就是时刻创造。
I'm also reflecting, Dave, that the process that you're describing to build a fire hydrant wrench also applies in some ways to interpersonal contexts and emotional situations. When we're working on something with someone, we're working as part of a team, when we are managing someone, when we're dealing with a boss, when we are thinking about a child or a partner or a spouse. All of these involve relationships that are under construction and in fact they're under construction all the time. And when you have that mindset, you're not trying to think about,
戴夫，我也在思考，你所描述的制造消防栓扳手过程，在某种程度上也适用于人际交往背景和情感状况。当我们和某人一起合作某事时，当我们作为团队的一部分工作时，当我们管理某人时，当我们与老板打交道时，当我们考虑孩子、伴侣或配偶时。所有这些都涉及处于建设中的关系，事实上，它们一直在建设中。当你有了这种心态，你就不会去想：
okay, there is a perfect place I'm going to get to with this other person. And once we get to that place, we're going to be happy forever. We're going to live happily forever, as the fairy tale say. In some ways, it takes the pressure off the outcome and gives us more enjoyment in the process. Absolutely. And one of the little tools we've invented for that is the got-to-get-to shift. When you're thinking transactionally, you're in the transactional world, it's all about getting it done.
好吧，我和这个人之间将达到一个完美的地方。一旦我们到了那个地方，我们就会永远快乐。我们会幸福地生活在一起，就像童话里说的那样。在某种程度上，这减轻了对结果的压力，让我们在过程中获得更多乐趣。绝对是的。我们为此发明的小工具之一就是“必须去”（got-to-get-to）的转变。当你以交易的思维思考时，你处于交易世界中，一切都是为了完成任务。
So I've got to get this thing done. You've got to get through this meeting. I've got to get these people to agree. I've got to sign this contract. I've got to get these tasks assigned, whatever that might be. You know, as opposed to, I get to participate in this process. There's a lovely illustration that I think I had permission to use. Our editor, who's working with us on this book, is, you know, she's working at home remote one day.
所以我必须把这件事情做完。你必须熬过这个会议。我必须让这些人达成一致。我必须签署这份合同。我必须分配这些任务，无论那可能是什么。你知道，与之相反的是：我有幸参与这个过程。有一个很棒的插图，我想我有权限使用它。我们的编辑，和我们一起合作这本书的人，你知道的，有一天她在家远程工作。
And her child is in the other room making a bunch of noise while she's about to go on to a Zoom call. you know, and she started saying to herself, I've got to find her way to get this kid to quiet down while I'm working. And then she suddenly remembered, oh yeah, she had just read the got-to get-to idea in the manuscript and said, no, no, no. I get to work at home now, which means
她的孩子在另一个房间制造了一堆噪音，而她正准备加入一个Zoom会议。你知道，她开始对自己说：我得想办法让这孩子在我工作时安静下来。然后她突然想起，哦对了，她刚刚在手稿中读到了“必须去到有幸去”（got-to get-to）的想法，然后说：不，不，不。我现在可以在家里工作，这意味着
I get to be in the presence of the effervescent sound coming out of this very alive child. I still get to work in the presence of that. I can put on my headphones and solve that problem easily. I'm so lucky that I get to be here. and be a part of that. Now, how do I, I've got to find her to shut the kid up.
我能够沐浴在来自这个充满生机的孩子的欢快声音中。我仍然可以在这种氛围中工作。我可以戴上耳机轻松解决那个问题。我是如此幸运，能够来到这里并成为其中的一部分。而刚才，我却想着：我得找人让这孩子闭嘴。
And she said, and that took about two seconds to have that change of mind and everything changed. So that's what we're looking for. We're looking for, see it a different way, and have a surprising change of your psychic experience of your own life.
她说，这种心态的转变花了两秒钟，一切都变了。这就是我们所追求的。我们所追求的是：以不同的方式看待事物，并对你对自己生活的心理体验产生一种惊人的转变。
And, of course, many of us discover this too late, Dave. You know, when we lose someone in our lives, we now say, you know, I would give anything to have that person back with us, even though when they were with us, We were often frustrated by them or irritated by them or wishing that they would say or do something different. And of course, we recognize that we are actually happy with all those things when we don't have that person anymore.
当然，我们中的许多人发现这一点时为时已晚，戴夫。你知道，当我们生命中失去某个人时，我们现在会说，你知道的，我愿意付出一切让那个人回到我们身边，尽管当他们在我们身边时，我们经常对他们感到沮丧或恼火，或者希望他们说或做一些不同的事情。当然，我们意识到，当那个不在了的时候，我们其实对所有那些事情都感到幸福。
Yeah, you know, I had this experience in my 20s in my career where I suddenly realized that I was living entirely in the future that I would never get to. And then there was a time I was talking with an intensive care unit nurse about this problem of always the next thing, always the next thing. you know, get there and then get the next goal, then the next goal. And frankly, you're never really enjoying the meal you're just trying to get it over with. And she said, oh, yeah, yeah, we have a term for that. We call it destination sickness. I go, what the heck is destination sickness? She goes, oh, yeah, you know, here in the ICU, particularly at Stanford, we have all these highly accomplished people.
是的，你知道，我在20多岁时有过这样的职业经历，当时我突然意识到，我完全生活在那个我永远也抵达不到的未来里。然后有一次，我正和一位重症监护室（ICU）护士谈论这种“总是追求下一件事、总是追求下一件事”的问题。你知道，到达那里然后追求下一个目标，再下一个目标。坦白说，你从来没有真正享受过眼前的这顿饭，你只是想快点把它吃完。她说，哦，对，对，我们对此有个术语。我们称之为目的地 sickness（目的地综合征）。我说，到底什么是目的地综合征？她说，哦，对，你知道，我们这里的ICU，特别是在斯坦福，有各种各样非常有成就的人。
And it was always, you know, when I finish the degree and then I want to get the grad degree, and then I want to get the good job, and then I make partner, and then I make my first million. And it's always that next thing will make me happy. And she said, and some of the people here, like the ones in their, mid-50s who've burned their heart out and now they're actually going to die. There's nothing more we can do for them. They suddenly realize there is no next thing. And then they look back at all the things they ran through and they realized they missed the whole thing. And frankly, she said, and most of them die in despair and realize it's too late. I mean, I shuddered at the
总是，你知道的，当我完成学位，然后我想获得研究生学位，然后我想找到好工作，然后我成为合伙人，然后我赚到第一个一百万。总是下一件事会让我快乐。她说，这里的一些人，比如那些55岁左右、燃尽了心血、现在实际上快要死了的人。我们已经无能为力了。他们突然意识到根本没有下一件事。然后他们回首自己匆忙跑过的所有事情，意识到他们错过了整个人生。坦白说，她说，他们中的大多数人在绝望中死去，意识到一切都太迟了。我的意思是，我听到这里不寒而栗，
I said, oh my God, she goes, oh yeah, it's really rough. By the way, here's a tip. Don't do that. Are the challenges we face in designing our lives the same as we go through different stages of our lives? Turns out, they are not. Designing your life when you are a high school or college student is a very different challenge than designing your life when you're in the thick of a career or when you're contemplating retirement. In our companion episode, available exclusively for our subscribers on Hidden Brain Plus, we look at how different design strategies apply to different stages of our lives. If you're all a subscriber, that episode is available right now in this podcast feed. It's titled,
我说：天哪！她说：哦，是的，真的很残酷。顺便给个建议：别那样做。我们在设计生活时面临的挑战，在我们经历不同人生阶段时是一样的吗？事实证明，并非如此。当你是一名高中生或大学生时，设计你的生活，与当你正处于职业生涯的漩涡中或考虑退休时，是完全不同的挑战。在我们面向“隐藏的大脑+”（Hidden Brain Plus）订阅者的独家专属加更剧集中，我们探讨了不同的设计策略如何适用于我们生活的不同阶段。如果你已经是订阅者，那一集现在就可以在你的播客源中收听。它的标题是：
Seasons of Meaning. If you're not yet a subscriber, please consider signing up. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hiddenbrain. You can get a free trial in both places, and you'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content. Again, that's support.diddenbrain.org, or Apple.co slash hidden brain. Dave Evans and Bill Burnett are co-authors of how to live a meaningful life, using design thinking to unlock purpose, joy, and flow every day. Dave, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
意义的季节（Seasons of Meaning）。如果你还不是订阅者，请考虑注册。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com/hiddenbrain。你在两处都可以获得免费试用，并且你将立即访问我们所有的订阅者专属内容。再说一遍，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co/hiddenbrain。戴夫·埃文斯（Dave Evans）和比尔·伯内特（Bill Burnett）是《如何过有意义的生活》（How to Live a Meaningful Life）一书的合著者，该书运用设计思维在每一天解锁目标、快乐与心流。戴夫，非常感谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。
Thanks, Shuckers. It's great to be here. Do you have questions or comments about how to live a more meaningful life? Have you felt stuck in life but then found a way forward? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with a hidden brain audience or if you have a question or comment about design thinking, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the audio file to us using the email address,
谢谢你，香卡。很高兴来到这里。你对如何过更有意义的生活有什么问题或评论吗？你是否曾在生活中感到迷茫，但随后找到了前进的方向？如果你有一个愿意与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享的个人故事，或者你对设计思维有任何问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在你的手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将音频文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱地址是：
Feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, stuck. Again, that email address is feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Our conversation with Dave Evans continues next week. Many of us think of meaning as something we find. But meaning is really something we design. By staying curious, experimenting, and reframing our challenges, we can create lives that feel purposeful and grounded instead of rushed and depleted.
Feedback at hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请使用：stuck。再次重复，邮箱地址是 feedback at hiddenbrain.org。我们与戴夫·埃文斯的对话将于下周继续。我们许多人认为“意义”是我们去寻找的东西。但意义实际上是我们设计出来的。通过保持好奇心、不断试验和重新构筑我们的挑战，我们可以创造出充满目标感和脚踏实地感的生活，而不是匆忙和精疲力竭的生活。
In our conversation next week, we focus on what may be the most difficult challenge in designing our lives. It isn't about where we want to go. It's about accepting where we are right now. Please tune in for it. It's titled Radical Acceptance. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury.
在下周的对话中，我们将聚焦于设计生活中最具挑战性的难题。它无关乎我们想去哪里。而是关于接纳我们现在的处境。请收听下期节目。它的标题是：激进接纳（Radical Acceptance）。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑”传媒（Hidden Brain Media）制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·克雷尔（Laura Querell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德ルー·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you like this episode, please share it with a couple of friends. Word of mouth recommendations are the way most people find their way to our show. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行主编。如果你喜欢这集节目，请与几位朋友分享。口口相传的推荐是大多数人找到我们节目的途径。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们很快再见。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。